[Music]
look so handsome
was all gone yes
[Music]
at 18 you see
clear
[Music]
was taken
you could give it
opening up for the first time in the
emotional and heartbreaking song make
you Lindsay l reveals she was sexually
assaulted speaking with People magazine
the singer says quote I was raped when I
was 13 and it happened again when I was
21 the song only talks about the first
time it's just a difficult thing to talk
about
and it's something that I process every
day still
[Music]
Phoebe
[Applause]
it's too
sharing the horrendous details to people
out Friday Lyndsey explains the first
assault happened at a church it was a
friend of the family and he groomed her
I felt like I had really messed up that
everybody was going to judge me and that
the rest of my life was ruined she
didn't tell anyone about the attack
not even her parents until she was 20
years old they had no idea it happened
and they were absolutely horrified I'm
so grateful towards both of them because
they helped me not go into any unhealthy
mechanisms to cope Lindsay went into
therapy to help deal with the trauma but
a year later she was raped again telling
the magazine that it was different and a
lot more violent the 31 year old country
star is now sharing her story with the
world to help others and launching the
make you movement a charity fund that
helps survivors of sexual assault and
domestic abuse as well as at-risk youth
Lindsay will also be donating proceeds
from her song make you Terrain the rape
abuse and incest national network and is
encouraging others to speak out about
the pain they may be going through the
minute you put a voice to your story the
shame has no power I hear you and I see
you you're not broken and you are worthy
of incredible things
[Music]
to
[Music]
that's what's gone
[Music]